Pat Mitchell: 11 years ago,
you, your sister --
Glenn Close: 14 years ago.
PM: 14 years ago!
Your sister, your nephew and yourself
made this courageous decision
to step forward and say,
"Our family has suffered
from mental illness,"
at a time when very few people
were talking publicly.
What led to this decision for the family?
GC: My sister Jessie, my younger sister,
always the wild one --
my dad, who was a doctor, actually said,
"Pull up your socks,
get back to work, get an education."
She came up to me one summer,
having put her kids in the car,
and she said, "I need your help.
I can't stop thinking
about killing myself."
I was in shock.
I had absolutely no clue,
no clue of what she was dealing with.
So my mom and I were able to get her help.
Her son Calen suffers from schizophrenia.
Lives with schizophrenia.
And together they came to me and said,
"We have -- we're trying to learn
how to manage our illnesses,"
which in long-term recovery means
you have to change meds.
It's how many meds? It's what --
It's a process and it's a long process,
and you have to be very resilient.
But they said, "We have found
that the stigma
around what we are dealing with
can be worse than
the diseases themselves."
When Calen came back
from two years in a psychiatric hospital,
none of his friends came back.
They still haven't come back,
even though he's become this advocate.
It's incredible to me.
So I said, because they're my family,
I said, "Of course, I will help you,
but you have to do it with me
because it's not about me, it's about you,
and it's about our family."
But their courage
still brings me to my knees.
Because no one was talking about it.
PM: And yet this silent epidemic,
which it still is in many ways, continues.
So you and your family took another step.
You founded an organization
called Bring Change to Mind.
GC: I learned about mental health advocacy
at Fountain House in New York,
and when we decided
that I wanted to do something,
I wanted to start an organization,
many generous, wonderful people
who had their own organizations,
the head of Fountain House included,
sat in that library,
and one of them went online and said,
"What's available? What's available?
Oh, Bring Change to Mind.
OK, let's use that."
(Laughter)
I mean, I didn't even know
I had to have a board.
(Laughter)
So --
PM: I think many people
recognize that moment.
GC: Yeah.
And that was, oh my gosh,
that was a huge adventure.
And I thought that my main contribution
would be making PSAs and things like that.
We have evolved.
We now have established over --
it's 540 clubhouses in 43 states.
(Applause)
And the thing that I'm very proud of
are the kids, because it's peer-to-peer.
It's not high schools that write to us.
It's the kids that write to us.
The kids say, "We want, we need
a Bring Change to Mind club
in our high school."
And I've met a lot of them,
and they are phenomenal.
(Applause)
PM: And that is transformative.
GC: Yeah. I think there's
about 14,000 kids now
with, you know, a waiting list always.
PM: So providing this kind
of peer-to-peer experience,
especially among teenagers,
where the suicide rate
and other forms of mental illness
have been just escalating,
was a big first step.
GC: Yeah.
PM: But you took it beyond that.
You went to Washington.
You talked publicly
about the lack of resources
to treat families
suffering with mental illness.
There were some accomplishments, right?
There have been some successes.
GC: Yeah. It's actually
very, very exciting.
And we're at a point where our government
has a bipartisan bill.
They have put aside 8.5 billion dollars
in the next 10 years
to establish what we're calling,
what they are calling Certified
Community Behavioral Health Clinics
in every state of the union --
(Applause)
And whatever town or county needs them.
Look into it, because we all
should have it in our counties, at least,
in our towns, in our cities,
because actually
we're in a crisis of care.
PM: And, Glenn,
I know that you were the first
to always say about this subject,
"I'm not a mental health expert.
I'm not a doctor.
I came into this
for very personal reasons."
But I'm sure there are
many people listening to us today
who are thinking, "Are there signs?
Are there symptoms,
are there things I should look for?"
You said yourself you didn't realize
how much Jessie was suffering.
GC: Oh, not at all.
PM: What clues, what things did you see?
GC: First of all, I think --
My sister Jessie wrote
a book called "Resilience."
She's so incredibly honest.
And she talks about her own journey
with bipolar disorder,
but also her son, when he had
his psychotic break at 19,
she didn't know what was happening.
She didn't know what was going on.
You know, he was thinking
the television was speaking to him.
He was afraid that the CIA was outside.
She had no clue.
And he would, you know, he'd be like this.
And it was a friend of hers
who had taken psychiatry in college,
who said, "Jess, let me spend
a little time with him."
And she said, "I think
he has schizophrenia."
And --
It was because of that friend.
I mean, Jessie would have, of course,
if that friend hadn't stepped up,
I'm sure, you know,
found some answers to his behavior.
But that's actually --
I think people hopefully are learning
about that kind of thing.
But I think it's the anxiety,
it's the depression,
it's suicidal ideation,
it's food disorders
that people can so easily hide.
And the thing you need to be --
vigilant about is a change in behavior
that lasts over --
Like, yes, we all can be depressed
for four or five days,
the weather changes,
you've lost a boyfriend
or, you know, God forbid someone has --
you're mourning a death.
But this is different.
And when you observe that,
you have to say, "Are you OK?"
And even if they say yes,
and you feel differently,
you have to say it again.
"Are you OK?"
Until you get --
what's happening.
PM: And how are they today? Jessie and --
GC: Oh, Jessie.
(Sighs)
Jess --
I almost hate to use the words,
it's so overused,
but Jessie is my true hero.
Both Calen and Jessie.
I have to tell you, she weeps.
The meds are hard. She has emphysema.
She was a wild woman
and smoked a lot of cigarettes.
(Laughter)
But she weeps and says,
"I don't want to be this way.
And the meds, they're going to
shorten my life."
And she has six grandchildren.
Now, that's hard.
It's hard. And --
Sometimes I say --
She said to me once,
"I guess I'm the family --"
What is it, black sheep? No.
I guess I'm -- it's not
the experimental lamb.
I forget the word. Anyway.
Why, out of all of us, was it her?
Why was it Calen?
We've learned so much.
But so for --
I live across the yard from my sister.
When I'm home,
I'm over there all the time.
Pippy, my dog,
kind of has a thing going on
with one of her little dogs.
(Laughter)
He won't admit it, but it's obvious.
And I try, you know,
I try to get her out of the chair.
You know, "Let's go for a drive."
You know, "Do you want to go
walk around the block?
Let's get our other sister
and, you know, let's just try to get,
you know, movement and light.
So it's a constant thing.
Now, Calen is a beautiful man.
He's married to -- He's married.
He's been married
for, I think, 10, 11 years.
And he's a painter. He's a painter.
And --
He once, early on,
after he came out of the hospital
and he was brave enough
to go to a local art class,
he decided that he should tell the teacher
that he was living with schizophrenia.
So he got up his courage and he said,
"Sir, I just want you to know
that I'm living with schizophrenia."
And the teacher said,
"Don't come back."
(Audience) Oh...
He is a fabulous painter.
(Applause)
PM: This -- These stories,
they do remind us
of how big that stigma is still,
as one of the biggest barriers
to people getting the help.
And Glen, there's just
such gratitude that we all feel
for the courage that you had, and your --
I know, but you fought for your sister
and for your nephew, and for all.
GC: Yeah. Now we've got to scale it out.
We have to scale out this community
health care system we have.
It's a crisis of care.
You know, the treatments are there.
And they work, and people can recover.
But you can't just treat people
when they have a break,
and you give them a couple of meds.
You've got to be in it for the long haul.
And we have to have structures like that
across our country.
PM: And because of your work,
we will have more
and because of the work
of Bring Change to Mind and --
(Applause)
(Audience) Aww!
GC: Pippy!
(Laughter)
Here you are! Here you are!
PM: This is Mr. Pip, everyone.
(Laughter)
GC: Pippy!
PM: I think this is
your mental illness companion.
GC: It is.
Do you have anything to say?
Do you want to speak?
Good job!
PM: Thank you, everyone.
GC: Thank you.